read about hundreds of thousands
of love stories that come from all over the world
which is a very beautiful thing i
am giovanna tamassia and i run the juliet
club in verona
thanks to shakespeare many tourists
visitors come verona for the story
of my juliet and letter juliet
arrive
since almost a hundred years in verona it is a
phenomenon that has seen
an increase especially in the
90s letters have become thousands and
thousands in all languages and it was then
hat we thought of creating clubs
and juliet this
roup of people who  the
thousands of letters in all the languages
world dedicate themselves to this particular activity of answering, there are about 10 thousand every year to which
we are able to answer the keeper of th
tomb of Juliet Hatton and Solim
ni began to collect and respo
d to the first letters she found
in this tourist site which was
precisely Juliet's tomb and he
began to respond by signing the
seg  retario di giulietta and therefore the
tradition born in this way and
continues today
whoever writes to juliet normally has a
love problem and therefore
asks and asks for advice tells
his story we try to answer in the
best possible way give the
most advice  right or in any case a word of
friendship and understanding
the concept of love I do not think it is
universal
in the letters we can see from what
people write how much love is
still experienced as one of the most
important things in life ever are about 30
years  because that we do this work
that we read letters but love has not
changed the importance of the feeling
of love
remains in remains unchanged both in time
and in space with all the countries of the
world